[Musique]
malaise autour de la distribution
gratuite d'un journal plusieurs milliers
de canadiens ont reçu ce journal dans
leur boîte aux lettres au cours des
dernières semaines
à la une de cette édition spéciale du
epoch times une manchette choc
comment le parti communiste chinois mais
le monde en danger
vous avez été très nombreux à nous
écrire au sujet de cette publication
pour hip hop dayz la pandémie de kobe 19
est l'occasion rêvée de tirer à boulet
rouge sur son ennemi juré le parti
communiste chinois qui tient en grande
partie responsables de la crise
sanitaire mondiale
l'équipe éditoriale pousse même la note
en titrant à la une couverture exclusive
du virus du pcc voilà qui rappelle
l'étiquette de virus chinois fréquemment
employées par des entreprises
cette édition spéciale ce journal a
dépeint le parti au pouvoir à pékin
comme la source maléfique d'un virus dit
communiste
selon cette logique le remède ultime
c'est de mettre fin au régime du parti
communiste chinois
tous les articles de cette édition
spéciale prennent exclusivement pour
cible le pouvoir central à pékin faut
dire que cette prise de position anti
pcc n'est pas très surprenante pour leur
époque times est fondée aux états unis
en 2000 par des américains d'origine
chinoise issue du mouvement falun gong
un courant spirituel banny est
persécutée en chine depuis 1999 quand on
regarde d'un peu plus près cette édition
de l'époque times on constate qu'un peu
plus du tiers du contenu est composée
d'éditoriaux ou d'articles d'opinion
plusieurs d'entre eux oui aborde de
front des questions déjà soulevé par
plusieurs médias dans le monde incluant
les décrypteurs sur notamment la
question du manque de fiabilité des
statistiques de dessin fournis par la
chine et la persécution des sonneurs
d'alert ça c'est vrai mais ces contenus
plutôt fiable côtoie aussi des demi
vérités et des inexactitudes dans cette
publication distribué un peu partout au
canada dans les deux langues officielles
le meilleur exemple c'est celui d'un
article qui affirme que les pays des
plus touchées par la kobe 19 sont les
pays qui ont davantage de liens
commerciaux avec la chine
quand on compare le classement des pays
les plus touchés avec le classement des
plus grands partenaires commerciaux de
la chine
on voit que cette théorie ne tient tout
simplement pas la route
j'invite les gens à les consulter mon
article à ce sujet sur notre site web
n'oubliez pas d'adhérer à notre groupe
facebook ou 6 ou d'écouter notre
émission dès samedi et dimanche allez
salut
[Musique]